you almost start to feel bad for him  except that you don't  um as proceedings were going on just  sitting by himself on his phone and we  have video of it um right now that we're  showing you sitting uh by himself  looking dejected sulking in the house  chamber  um on his phone and just nobody talking  to him you let me know whether you feel  bad I mean listen he he lied about  everything you know this guy really  really did lie about everything and now  I mean listen it's not like Republicans  are honest it's not like I have a  delusion that the reason Republicans are  shunning him is because they're honest  and this guy is dishonest obviously  that's not the case uh but it is just  funny and kind of like weird to see  um there he is picking his nose and  we'll actually look at that moment a  little more closely that was a much  scrutinized moment almost like the  Zapruder film